SEND IT BACK TO YOU.
>> Sandra: THANK YOU.
>> Bill: LET'S GET REACTION.
SENATOR TOM COTTON.
WELCOME BACK TO OUR PROGRAM AND
GOOD MORNING TODAY.
HERE ARE THE NUMBERS ALONG THE
SOUTHERN BORDER TO DATE IN
FISCAL YEAR-TO-DATE, 1.9
MILLION.
WE WILL TOP 2 MILLION EASILY.
BUSED TO WASHINGTON 9400, NEW
YORK CITY 1100, CHICAGO 500.
NOW A FEW DOZEN IN MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
YOUR REACTION TO THE BACK AND
FORTH NOW.
>> THE HYPOCRISY OF THESE
LIBERALS IS JUST AMAZING.
JOE BIDEN HAS PRESIDED OVER A
SLOW MOTION INVASION OF OUR
COUNTRY SINCE HE TOOK OFFICE.
ALMOST 4 MILLION ILLEGAL
MIGRANTS HAVE CROSSED INTO OUR
COUNTRY AND THERE ARE BORDER
TOWNS INCLUDING EL PASO AS WE
HEARD FROM BILL MELUGIN WHO
HAVE THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL
MIGRANTS ARRIVING EVERY SINGLE
DAY.
YET WHEN A FEW THOUSAND ARRIVE
IN WASHINGTON, D.C. THEY
DECLARE A STATE OF EMERGENCY.
WHEN THEY GET TO CHICAGO THEY
CALL OUT THE NATIONAL GUARD.
WHEN 50 GET TO MARTHA'S
VINEYARD THE LIBERAL MEDIA GOES
INTO A FIVE ALARM FIRE.
THESE COMMUNITIES ARE SO
HYPOCRITICAL BECAUSE THEY ARE
NOT WILLING TO BEAR THE BRUNT
OF JOE BIDEN'S IMMIGRATION
FAILURES.
REMEMBER, JOE BIDEN IS DOING
THE EXACT SAME THING.
HE IS TRANSPORTING MIGRANTS ALL
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
JUST LIBERALS WANT TO DECIDE
WHERE ILLEGAL MIGRANTS GO.
APPARENTLY ALL THE RITCHIE
LEETS ON MARTHA'S VINEYARD
DON'T WANT THEM IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
WHY SHOULD COMMUNITIES IN
ARIZONA AND TEXT VAST TO BEAR
THAT BURDEN?
MORE FUNDAMENTALLY WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS THAT DOUG DUCEY AND GREG
ABBOTT AND THE PEOPLE OF
ARIZONA AND TEXAS WOULD MUCH
RATHER THAN SENDING BUSES AND
PLANES TO THE NORTH THAT JOE
BIDEN DO HIS JOB AND PROTECT
OUR BORDER AND SEND THE BUSES
AND PLANES TO THE SOUTH BECAUSE
THESE ILLEGAL MIGRANTS SHOULD
BE GOING BACK TO THEIR HOME
COUNTRIES.
THEY SHOULDN'T BE GOING
ANYWHERE IN AMERICA.
>> Sandra: YESTERDAY WE TOOK IT
LIVE THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS
BRIEFING HAPPENED FOLLOWING THE
VICE PRESIDENT'S COMMENTS OVER
THE WEEKEND THAT THE BORDER IS
SECURE.
OBVIOUSLY REPUBLICANS ARE
DIRECTLY RESPONDING TO THOSE
COMMENTS.
THE PRESS SECRETARY WAS GIVEN A
CHANCE TO WALK THOSE WORDS BACK.
SHE INSTEAD CHOSE TO DOUBLE
DOWN.
LISTEN.
SHE BACKED UP THE CLAIM THAT
THE BORDER IS INDEED SECURE.
SO I'LL ASK YOU THEY ARE
TOUTING THESE NUMBERS THAT THEY
ARE APPREHENDING AND REMOVING
OR EXPELLING MORE MIGRANTS THAN
EVER AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER,
SENATOR.
BUT PUT THAT IN CONTEXT FOR US.
ONE NEEDS TO POINT OUT THERE
ARE MORE MIGRANTS THAN EVER
POURING OVER OUR BORDER.
SO THEY'RE HAVING TO EXPEL OR
REMOVE MORE MIGRANTS THAN EVER.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT, SANDRA.
WE HAVE HAD ALMOST 4 MILLION
ILLEGAL MIGRANTS CROSS INTO OUR
COUNTRY SINCE JOE BIDEN.
IT IS NOT THE RESULT OF
INCOMPETENCE OR BAD LUCK FOR
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS THEIR DELIBERATE POLICY
AND WHAT THEY WANTED AND WHAT
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS
CAMPAIGNED ON.
THE PRESS SECRETARY WOULDN'T
EVEN SAY MIGRANTS SHOULDN'T
COME TO THIS COUNTRY.
WOULDN'T SEND A MESSAGE YOU
SHOULDN'T MAKE THE JOURNEY TO
GET TO OUR BORDERS BECAUSE
THEY'RE INVITING ILLEGAL
MIGRANTS FROM ALL ACROSS THE
WORLD TO COME TO OUR COUNTRY.
THIS IS THE EXACT RESULT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WANTED.
WHEN IT IMPOSES HARDSHIP ON
DEMOCRATIC COMMUNITIES LIKE
WASHINGTON, D.C. THEY GO TO
DEATH COM ONE ABOUT IT WHEN